the Grammys happening a couple nights
ago and uh apparently all things
considered I guess um I didn't watch it
but looks like it wasn't a bad wasn't a
terrible show as these things go they
actually had some real musical
performances I think um and uh as far as
I saw on the clip circulating it
actually was a like a relatively decent
display of actual musical Talent at the
Grammys it seems like which is pretty
shocking um still not going to watch it
but you know credit where to and there
was one embarassing moment though which
came to us courtesy of uh Jay-Z um he
received some kind of Lifetime
Achievement Award or something and when
he got up to receive it he took the time
to complain of course as one does when
they win an award and uh here's what he
said I don't want to embarrass this
young lady but she has more Grammys than
everyone and never one album of the year
so even by your own metrics that doesn't
work think about that the most Grammys
never won an album of the year that
doesn't
work you know some of you some of you
going to go home tonight and feel like
you've been
robbed some of you may it
[Music]
ra some of you don't belong in the
category all no no no no no no I was
that no when I get nervous I tell the
truth um but outside of that
oh what a great guy um up there he's
winning I think it was a Lifetime
Achievement Award or something along
those lines and he he takes his time to
complain and then in randomly insult the
other people that have been nominated
for
awards these are just like these are
these are just the worst people in the
world you know you turn on these shows
and you see these are just the worst
human beings that the world has has to
offer and
um
and yet they're winning accolades so
Beyonce has won like 30 gramms or
something like that I think a little bit
more than 30 more than anyone and yet he
still complains that she hasn't won more
she's still being persecuted because
although she's won more than anyone and
probably didn't deserve any of them she
she hasn't won album of the year and so
uh she's still put upon still
persecuted the most grammies out of
anyone now not enough not enough uh
agulation not enough admiration not
enough
recognition it's just funny when they
keep trying to do this with Beyonce in
particular they are determined to turn
her into a victim somehow this Mega
wealthy Superstar celebrity who's won
more award recognition than any musical
artist in history I mean really think
about that there have been me there are
a lot of terrible musicians these days
that that are not even really
musicians you think about all the true
Geniuses that we've seen in the music
industry over the last 70 years or so
and Beyonce has won more than any of
them but it's not enough still
complaining kind of
amazing um but then Jay-Z keeps talking
and he says something as he continues
after he's done complaining and
insulting people he gets into a a little
effort to be
inspiring and and what he says there I
think EX sort of shows what the problem
is what the real problem is so watch
this but outside of that outside of that
you know we got to keep showing up and
forget the Grammys for a second just in
life as I as my daughter sits and stares
at me nervous as I am
um um just in life you got to keep
showing up just keep showing up forget
the Grammys you got to keep showing up
until until they give you all those
accolades you feel you deserve until
they call you chairman until they call
you a genius until they call you the
okay so he says keep showing up keep
trying until they give you the accolades
you feel you deserve until they call you
a genius so notice the mentality there
it's not keep showing up keep working
hard until you've achieve something
meaningful in the world that's not what
he's saying it's keep showing up until
they give you
recognition like keep pursuing those ego
Strokes until your ego has been stroked
enough keeping windshields clean is
always a pain especially in the winter
that's why I'm so grateful to have
windshield wow windshield wow is an
Innovative windshield cleaning device
that uses two magnetic cleaning peddles
one on the outside one on the inside of
your car to clean both sides of your
windshield all from the outside being
able to clean both the front and the in
the inside window at the same time as a
game changer which I had one of these
years ago seriously all you got to do is
push around the outside paddle and the
inside follows automatically leaving
your windshield squeaky clean we had a
big snowstorm here in Nashville and with
all the dirt and salt piled up on the
roads washer fluid just couldn't do the
job luckily I had a windshield wow in my
trunk to save the day that's what's
awesome about the windshield wow it's so
easy to throw these in the back of your
car so you can always have a clean
windshield so what are you waiting for
go to windshield wow.com is code Walsh
should check out for a special discount
that's windshield wow.com use code Walsh
now this mentality may have driven Jay-Z
to become very successful uh financially
anyway and and ridiculously wealthy I
think he's a like a billionaire now or
something but this is terrible advice
for for pretty much everybody else
because if you're driven by a need for
recognition most likely you'll never
achieve
anything think about how passive that is
too keep going until they until they
give you what you deserve until they
recognize who's they it's like they it's
like other people out there have the key
to your happiness and you got to keep
proving yourself to them until they give
you until they unlock until they use the
key and unlock uh your happiness for you
um
and the thing is that that that is what
motivates a lot of people and every once
in a while you'll have somebody
motivated that way who does succeed
enormously but most people won't and if
that's what drives you most likely it
will drive you right into a ditch and
you'll never get past you won't get past
the first Mile right you'll barely even
drive out get out of your driveway
before you're in a ditch if that's what
drives you and I I I encounter people
like this all the time in uh in my
business as you might imagine who have
this obsessive need to be recognized and
credited and
applauded give me the credit give me the
recognition not just people in front of
the camera either I mean at every level
of the business you run into this and
um naturally any kind of business where
you're where you are around cameras and
TVs and stuff it's going to attract that
kind of mentality even more and here's
the thing the vast majority
of the people I meet who are like this I
need credit I need recognition I need to
be applauded I need this I vast majority
are not successful and probably never
will be because their motivations are
all entirely wrong if you want to
achieve anything worthwhile in life you
have to find a way to forget as much as
possible about recognition not worry
about that not worry about who gets the
credit right and pursue greatness
because it's
greatness
um you see all the time you see people
who are basically on the first rung of
the ladder or or haven't even made it on
the first rung yet and they're down
there screaming recognize me where's my
credit why are you saying nice things
about me give me
Applause and they're going to be there
whining forever they're stuck in this
paralysis uh that their need for
approval has has put them in
now there again there will be exceptions
Jay-Z extremely rich um but not a key to
success for most people and and the
thing is even if you do succeed with
that mentality as Jay-Z has just showed
you you still won't be happy so you
might be an exception and maybe this
obsessive need to be recognized does
actually because the other thing is if
that if on top of that you also have
enormous skill and talent and all that
um and and an ability to focus
obsessively on what you want in life you
might still
succeed but you'll NE just you'll never
be happy you will never be happy because
uh he and his wife have been called
Geniuses many
times
unduly uh they've been given every
Accolade every award every Crown you can
give someone they'd be given all of
it and it's still not enough still ing
still just
whining uh not happy that's that's where
it
leads if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there godp speed